تجدد تصعيد في غزه واسرائيل تغتال قياديا
صاروخ يحول فستان عروس الى كفن
ظاهره غريبه تثير الفزع في سماء اليابان
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
ونبدا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث تجدد
التصعيد الاسرائيلي في غزه مع تعثر
الوساطه المصريه لارساء تهدئه بين الطرفين
فيما اعلنت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي مقتل
القيادي في سرايا القدس احمد ابو دقه
باستهداف منزله في خان يونس مراسل العربيه
اوضح ان ابو دقه كان يشغل منصب قائد
الوحده الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس فيما
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي قصفى 166 هدفا
تابعا للحركه خلال العمليه التي اطلقها
منذ يوم الثلاثاء الماضي بينما اطلقت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه اكثر من 500 واربعين
صاروخا وقذيفه باتجاه اسرائيل
ومنذ اطلاق اسرائيل عمليتها العسكريه في
قطاع غزه تحت اسم السهم الواقي والتي خلفت
عددا من الضحايا الفلسطينيين تداول رواد
السوشيال ميديا قصصا ماساويه لهؤلاء وكانت
من ابرز هذه القصص الانسانيه صوره انتشرت
بشكل واسع من محادثه مع مسؤول احدى قاعات
الافراح لطلب الغاء حجز حفل زفاف كان
مقررا بعد شهر من الان والسبب هو مقتل
العروس بشظايا صاروخ اسرائيلي سقط بالقرب
من منزلها في غزه ومن ضمن الفيديوهات
المتداوله ايضا لاب يودع ابنه داخل
المستشفى بقوله راح الولد يا رب
الى امريكا هذه المره حيث حشدت سلطات 24
الف عنصر امن استعدادا لرفع الوشيك لاجراء
صحي كان معمولا به منذ بدايه جائحه كورونا
واتاح الترحيل الفوري للمهاجرين العابرين
برا النحو اراضيها من المكسيك هذه الخطوه
تاتي في وقت كان المهاجرون ينتظرون عند
حدود الولايات المتحده وتسود بينهم حاله
من الارتباك والقلق فيما اقر وزير الامن
الداخلي لخندرو مايوركاس بان الايام
والاسابيع المقبله قد تكون صعبه للغايه
مشيرا الى ان السلطات رصدت بالفعل عددا
كبيرا من المهاجرين الوافدين الى الحدود
الامريكيه
في اليابان افدت السلطاته بان خطوط
الناريه شوهدت ليلا في سماء جنوب البلاد
قد تكون ناجمه عن حطام صاروخ صيني فسالون
قالوا انهم يعتقدون بان تلك الاجسام ليست
كرات ناريه من نيازك بل هي حطام من صاروخ
الى انه قد يكون حطام صاروخ اطلقته الصين
في شهر نوفمبر الماضي واوضحوا ان الحطامى
سقط على الارجح في المحيط ولا يشكل اي خطر
استنادا الى توقعات المسار الذي كان يمكن
ان يسلكه فيما كان رواد مواقع التواصل
تداولوا فيديوهات تظهر ما يشبه كرات ناريه
اثارت حيره الكثيرين
اربع ساعات من النوم في الجو مقابل 250
دولار هذه رسوم تنوي شركه الطيران الوطنيه
النيوزيلنديه اطلاقها قريبا الشركه طرحت
نموذجها الاولي لتصميمات المقصورات
المخصصه للنوم في الجو المسماه عش السماء
هذا الاسبوع لكن الحجوزات ستكون متاحه فقط
اعتبارا من سبتمبر 202
فان المقصوره هي مكونه من طابقين وتتسع
لسته اشخاص كما سيشمل كل سرير وساده
وملاءات وبطانيه فيما اكدت في بيان لها ان
الفراش سوف يتغير بين كل جلسه واخرى